Next up, did you ever have your phone buzz
only to look down and read a text that says, "Can we talk?"
Oh my God.
Refinery29 reports that experts say
you should never text that to anyone.
If you text, "We need to talk,"
it immediately makes people think about
the absolute worst case scenarios.
It's a heart attack in a text message
and should never be done.
Rossy, thoughts.
Don't you dare text me this, okay?
Just come out and say it
because you know what I've done in that 18 seconds
between "Hey, we need to talk," and the bubble?
Is that I've decided everyone died, right?
Everyone's gone. They're just dead.
There's a bomb on the way. Hey, you know, boom.
So every single worst case scenario.
You know, they canceled "Bridgerton."
What? No!
What? Something terrible is coming.
Just give it to me straight.
(Drew laughs)
I feel like I've gotten a lot of them
in the last few years.
Like, they're constantly like an onslaught
of the "Can we talk" texts.
What would be a good alternative? Does anyone have an idea?
Yes, you!
What is your name?
I'm Jo.
Hi, Jo. I'm Drew, this is Ross.
Hi, Jo!
Hi!
I take it from a science point of view.
You state the problem
and come up with possible hypotheses and solutions.
Right away.
All in the same text?
All in the same text.
So you say, "Hey, here's a problem,
"this is what it is,
"this is what I think we should do about it,
"have a great day"?
Yes.
(audience laughs)
I agree.
I think stating the problem right there in text,
and then the possible solutions,
or at least a, "Now let's get into it."
Exactly.
What do you do for living, may I ask?
I'm a science teacher.
Yeah.
Oh, that explains it.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
There you go.
Cause and effect. Problem, solution.
Thank you, Jo.
I really think you did solve the problem
and I appreciate you endlessly.
Thank you, Jo.
Leave it to a science teacher.
(audience applauds)
All right, thanks Jo.
All right, next up it's Taco Time in today's Food News!
Num, num, num, num!
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Yes.
And we have some tacos here.
Travel + Leisure reports,
off the coast of the US Virgin Islands of Saint John
there floats a taco bar.
Lime Out is a taco stand
floating in the (laughs) Caribbean Sea.
You need a speed boat or a kayak
or a paddleboard to get there
and they serve up fresh fish tacos,
vegan tacos with paprika smoked black beans,
and plenty of iced craft cocktails to keep you cool.
Now, we couldn't get to this floating taco bar today,
unfortunately, but we do have some tacos right here, Drew.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
This is what I'm taco 'bout.
Um.
Yes?
I already started.
(Ross mumbles)
And listen,
I would swim in the middle of nowhere for a taco.
I just think this is neat and I wish,
'member "Cast Away," when Tom Hanks was just floatin'?
Can you imagine if he just was like, "(groans) Oh, tacos.
"Oh, oh.
(Drew laughs)
"This is so handy."
You're right!
If he'd only found
a floating taco cart.
A taco stand,
it could've come in really handy.
I love it!
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh-Oh-Oh ♪
♪ Oh-Oh-Oh-Oh ♪